three minister and director-general of
the CBI Lord Digby Jones they'd be good
to see you Sallie Railly good afternoon
this is Teresa may second visit in six
months she's obviously pretty keen on
the place well I'm very pleased she is
going out there and I'm very pleased
that there's a prime minister who's
travelling it's always difficult to get
prime ministers to get out and really
bang the jump drum for trade they do the
state visits but actually making it
business focused everybody watching this
every business woman every businessman
anybody who works in business people who
work in the public sector whose wages
depend on the taxes that come from the
profits made by business should be
really grateful tonight that we've got
the democratically leader of the country
actually sitting in one of our biggest
export markets as you just mentioned I
thought that was an excellent summary of
where these countries ranked and how
important they are and of course the the
enormous thing about this is the British
people are facing brexit and what they
voted for was exactly what Teresa Mae's
doing which is in the European Union
what Germany wants Germany gets and we
are saying actually we can do these
deals without the European Union
although we want them to be a really
good friend and we want them to be our
trading partners but Britain is a
trading nation and I heard and very
pleased you patch me into John Bruton
remarks beforehand because at the end of
the day we we will have a good trading
agreement with Europe but the one thing
membership of the EU doesn't allow us to
do is precisely what Theresa May is
doing today which is do your own deal
with countries with whom Britain has
excellent relations and can work for
Britain rather than for France or Italy
or anywhere else sure how tricky a line
does she have to tack though in Saudi
Arabia given that the Saudis are at
loggerheads with Qatar which as we've
just said is also another huge trading
partner well and also you know we are a
country in the European Union
this if you like where we really do
trade in with respect to human rights
and we don't do corruption in the way
that some other countries do and we
don't do protectionism in the way that
some members of the European Union do so
we are actually a different sort of
trading partner and I think that Britain
with her relationships in in the Gulf
and with Saudi actually by trade by
creating wealth for them and us it's an
easier thing you know to actually talk
about human rights talk about
loggerheads between two trading partners
as you say with Qatar and with Saudi
it's a it's an easier thing to do it
when it's in the best interest of
everybody to make money together when
you've not got a dominating partner when
you've not got someone patronizing and
preaching but doing it on the basis of
hey this is in the best interest of
everybody and I actually think we could
act as something of a catalyst in this
as well
I'm not for a minute thinking that we've
got the solution to issues in the Middle
East I don't mean that but I do mean
that actually if we can be seen to be
doing deals then it's in the interests
of everybody in a very sensitive part of
the world actually to think of improving
a lot of people there and here through
trade through business and it might just
help on the other stuff as well okay
Debbie Jones gonna leave with I'm afraid
good to see you thanks for joining me